[Music]
in this video you will learn how to
stream third-party application logs from
a google compute engine instance into
cloud logging using the ops agents the
ops agent is the primary agent for
collecting logs and telemetry from gce
instances and setting that data to your
google cloud project
the ops agent contains two parts open
telemetry for gathering metrics within
an instance such as cpu memorization
disk and swap usage and so forth
meanwhile fluent bit provides a flexible
and high throughput collection of
application logs and will be the focus
in this video
the ops engine supports several google
verified integrations with third-party
applications like mysql database apache
web server or a microsoft active
directory domain server check out the
link below for a complete list
you aren't limited to google verified
integrations if you have an application
that writes logs to a text file a tcp
port or to the system's logging service
then you can use the ops agent to send
those logs to your cloud project
the apps agent or specifically the
underlying fluent bit technology uses
the concept of a pipeline a pipeline
starts with a receiver that describes
how to collect the logs that the
application generates
then a processor describes how to
manipulate the information collected by
a receiver such as by modifying or
excluding the log entries this step
however is optional
the pipeline ends by dispatching the log
entry to cloud logging where all logs
can be queried and displayed in the
google cloud console
there are several documented and
supported ways to install the ops agent
depending on your deployment model to
install the ops agent on a fleet of
virtual machines you can either use
automation tools such as terraform or
ansible
or use the gcloud command line tool to
create agent policies however the
easiest way to get started is by
installing the agent on an individual vm
which we'll cover in this video
before installing the ops agent on an
individual vm make sure that the cloud
logging and monitoring api services are
enabled the vm has access to remote
package repositories either via the
public internet or by providing the vm
with private google access
and finally make sure that the instance
runs a supported operating system
to install the ops agent on an
individual linux vm do the following
from the compute engine page select the
target instance
click on the observability tab in the
instance details page and then click the
install ops agent button
this will provide a prompt to either
copy the installation command which can
be run on any other command line
interface that has a gcloud client
installed or run the command directly in
cloud gel
if you want to install the ops agent on
a windows vm or to install the ops agent
manually refer to the public
documentation there you'll find the
shell command that you can copy and
paste into the target's instances
command line terminal the ops agent does
not need any pre-configuration to run by
default the ops agent clicks only syslog
in linux or the windows event log
to collect logs from third-party
applications you will need to modify the
config yaml file which is stored in the
following directories in linux and
windows
the first step to configure third-party
application logging is to define one or
more receivers in this video we collect
log files from pacemaker an application
used to monitor sap systems but the same
steps can be applied to any other
application here a receiver is defined
by the id pacemaker-log it is configured
to retrieve logs from files in three
different paths in the local linux file
system then the next step is to define
one or more processors this step is
optional it describes how to manipulate
the information collected by a receiver
in this example the processor with the
id pacemaker dash exclude is configured
to exclude logs that contain the text
cib underscore file underscore backup
finally the pipeline with the id
pacemaker dash pipeline is where the
receiver and processor are linked
together to create a data flow into
cloud logging and completes this
configuration example
please note that the order of these
configurable parameters must come in
this exact order as described first
receivers then processors and finally
pipelines
to verify that everything is working
correctly go to cloud logging in google
cloud console filter for the application
logs click on the log name menu and
search for the pipeline id specified in
the config.yml file in this case the id
is pacemaker dash log
congratulations you are now able to view
the application logs in cloud logging
be sure to restart the ops agent service
to apply any changes made to the
config.yaml file using the exclude logs
processor has performance implications
so it's recommended that you avoid using
this processor if you can exclude logs
from the source directly
we recommend that you keep the agent up
to date to take advantage of any new
enhancements and features
using the agent policies you can enable
auto upgrade to have this managed for
you but you may also upgrade at any time
manually
to learn more about using the ops agent
check out the public documentation page
for more tutorials and videos thanks for
watching
[Music]
you